sometimes you will be in very very nice
time and very nice place but you
remember just it's a bad thing
[Music]
it is that God saying to you forget it
quickly buts about seeing stay I don't
know why sometimes I need a medicine and
I asked the doctor I want a medicine to
forget everything to start them an
intense battle to retake the Syrian city
[Music]
I have like I swear like two years I
cannot dream I don't have any dreams
when I sleep you know you know what I
mean yeah I don't have dreams like one
time I did three what I didn't forget
but it's like about my dad only one time
yeah I think it was like he was in our
home in Germany and I opened the door
and it was my dad you know and I don't
know he gave us ice cream or the flowers
I don't know I forget and then needed
come in and we only to speak about how
he where he was and what he did do and
all this stuff
[Music]
about the future I afraid to think about
the future in the past I can think and
what another step I go in my life
step to step I don't I don't think in a
lot of step look I have so many dreams
now the future are gonna be journalists
it's my big dream and I start start from
now
[Music]
[Applause]
hakuna Alemannia Thomas a criminal an
exterminator optimal l hope l acti
ramalho Ryan this is all my dream and I
want my children to sing in this thing
and this part I must give good person to
make causal for my country what aliens
of who bishop down while are amended on
me daddy raha wanna do who has in her
GLM billion
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I'd have to see to the beach and
listen a good song and to drink coffee
and I dream as I was there our our dream
is the Disneyland it's a dream for us oh
my god I wanna go there it's beautiful
right
[Music]
you